es una historia que ha sorprendido al
mundo entero la supervivencia de cuatro
niños en la selva del guaviare Colombia
tras 40 días ha perdido el primero de
mayo el avión en el que viajaban se
estrelló en la mitad de la selva pero
los menores de 5 9 13 y un año
sobrevivieron
el dispositivo de búsqueda dio con
pruebas de ello como un biberón fruta
mordisqueada o huellas pero a pesar de
estar muy cerca no consiguieron
encontrarlos hasta el 9 de junio y lo
más sorprendente con vida estaban en la
Vereda Palma Rosa a tan solo 5 km de
donde se estrelló su avión y a pesar de
tener signos de desnutrición con buen
estado de salud en general algo que hace
saltar una pregunta cómo lograron
sobrevivir 40 días en mitad de la selva
la respuesta se encuentra en la
cosmovisión indígena del mundo y la
conexión que tienen con la naturaleza
los grupos indígenas colombianos
aseguran que la misma selva los protegió
o posiblemente se encontraron con grupos
no contactados a presentes en la región
además los niños del pueblo indígena
huitoto en especial los dos mayores
sabían manejarse por la selva
la sobrevivencia de los niños es una
muestra del conocimiento y
relacionamiento con el medio natural de
la vida el cual se enseña desde el
vientre de la madre los indígenas no
entienden el mundo igual y según su
cosmovisión en la selva nunca se pierde
nadie es un tránsito del que se puede
volver o no un episodio que según dijo
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
quedará en la historia del país